hello and welcome to today's NCBI minute
on our updated or finder an open reading
frame prediction tool I'm Wayne Matten
with me today is Peter Cooper and you
can see on this slide the closed
captioning information go ahead and put
in your questions in the question pod as
you think of them Peter may very well be
able to answer those while I'm talking
but we'll put it those in a document and
any that we get after I quit talking
into a link in materials on the webinars
and courses page and I'll just go ahead
and show you that page so this is
webinars and courses
this is today's webinar but that will
before very long move over to the
archived page and there you see a link
in our previous webinars to materials so
those questions and answers will be
there there are no slides from today
eventually there'll be a video file in
materials and we'll also post a
recording on our youtube channel
probably get that up within the next
several days if you have questions about
our finder after we stop the webinar
feel free to go ahead and email me at
Matson ma tten at NCBI NLM dot and now h
gov or you can send general NCBI
questions to that info email alias so
this is intended to be a very short
minute so let me go ahead and jump over
to the or finder page you can find this
in a web search if you search for NCBI
or finder you may well come upon the old
or finder page but there's a link there
to this page and the URL is simply the
base NCBI homepage URL /o rff I nder all
lowercase so what's new in nor finder
now primarily it's the interface
it looks more like many of our other
resources you'll see that particularly
on the results page but we do now also
have a standalone version you can
download that by name
here at this Linux x64 link and the
standalone version does not have the
limitation of processing 50 KB that the
web version does the other addition is
you can now send your translated Orff's
directly to smart blast and we still
maintain the ability to send it to the
full blastp service as well
just a quick caveat before I demonstrate
our finder is not intended to be you
know a gene prediction tool particularly
for eukaryotes it works in many cases
fine as an or finder in bacterial and
archaeal genomes viral genomes and also
for eukaryotic transcripts I'm not going
to demonstrate the transcripts today but
there's a link here to demonstrate that
for you if you want to look at that what
I'm going to do today is enter an
accession for an archaea you know m'q
sequence there's that refseq accession
this sequence is actually close to three
million nucleotides long
I could put in some coordinates here and
from and - but or finder will
automatically stop the processing at
about 50 KB so I'm not going to bother
with that you have a few options here
I'm going to go ahead and select a
slightly larger minimal or flank just to
clean up my results a bit you may or may
not want to do that depending on your
goals and your sequences I know I'm
looking at an RPO sequence so I'll go
ahead and select genetic code 11 and I'm
going to choose to include alternative
initiation codons you may in some cases
want to use this any sense codon option
particularly if you have a feeling that
your sequence may not begin at at the
beginning of the open reading frame so
if you choose any sense codon you'll be
able to perhaps walk upstream to a
different initiation codon okay and I'm
going to go ahead and check ignore
nested Orff's again primarily just to
clean up my output because this is a
fairly long input sequence I'll click
the submit button and this is
running in real-time this is very fast
and given the conditions I had it found
115 Orff's and it reminds me that I that
had calculated that on the first 50 KB I
can also notice that by sliding over
here in the viewer and see that the
processing stopped right about 50 K okay
so those of you familiar with our gene
records and in our genome browsers will
recognize this graphical viewer as our
sequence viewer and so it has the same
controls for zooming very similar list
of tools and I'll point out a couple of
those later that you might like and then
below that graphical view is a table
that's sorted initially by length of the
orb so the longest orfs on top but these
columns are all sortable so for example
you might want to see the Orff's in the
order on the input sequence strand or
input sequence so I'm going to go down
here and select or 46 it's the first
longest one and when I select that it
then gets highlighted up here with a
marker in the sequence viewer now many
of you are used to using a six frame
translations and/or finder to do that
here you click this button add the 6
frame translation track because this is
sequence viewer it adds that track and
I'm zoomed out too far to see any detail
here so let's go ahead and zoom in on
this first large or 446 I'll mass over
that marker name and that gives me the
option then to zoom to sequence marker
so I'll click that and now I'm zoomed
all the way into the sequence the
shading here represents the beginning of
our 46 and you can see that in fact it
used a CTG as an alternate initiation
codon to begin the orphe
and down in the table you can see that
this is in frame +3 so let's take a look
at the six frame train six frame
translation plus three and we see here's
the ATG Metheny and down just a little
bit farther another ATG meth I mean and
so that would be a good use of blast
perhaps to see if we can get some
information about what other related
proteins actually start with and we'll
do that in just a minute but first let's
look at some of the other options we
have on this results page so you notice
a button here that's grayed out at the
moment that says download marked set so
I could mark all one 15 of these or so
with this button or I can pick and
choose Orff's so how do you mark them
you have one selected here you're
looking at the translation here in the
Box on the left then you can mark that
one that you're viewing so that changes
the color and the table and it actually
puts a little gray box around the or FUP
in the viewer so let's say I want to
select now or 47 I click on that in the
table now it's being displayed on the
left the translation is and then I can
mark that one as well so now I have two
marked Orff's up in the sequence viewer
and so now my button to download mark
set is active and I can download then
either fast asn.1 or a feature table
format you'll notice here that's grayed
out you can't select it at the moment is
CD s fast eh that's because this is not
implemented yet but hopefully will be
before too long and that will allow you
to download the nucleotide fast day for
that coding sequence region okay
and marking these also allowed us to use
blast mark set so these two buttons will
send the translations off to the
standard blast P page you can select a
database here but you get to the full
page where you can select other
databases as well and you also have all
the algorithm parameters you can play
with I'm just going to demonstrate smart
blast
smart blast does not have a smart blast
the mark set button because smartblast
will take only one query sequence at a
time so if you do want to analyze
multiple orbs at once with blasts use
the full blast P algorithm I'm going to
go ahead and unmarked this or 47 so I
have this up here I can click unmarked
now I have just one of these mark but I
want to blast 46 not 47 so I click on
that again in the table and that loads
or 46 up here so the question is which
of these methionine x' might be the
actual one that's used as the initiation
codon so note those up here and I'll go
ahead and click on smart blast and again
this is also running in real time and
it's finished if you're not familiar
with smart blast we had a webinar on
that back in September so you can check
that out on our YouTube channel this did
in fact search the NR database but it
uses a faster algorithm so that's why it
comes back so quickly it searches
another database are called landmark
with a much smaller set of sequences but
that's detail we don't need to worry
about today and we got some names here
which means we probably got some pretty
decent hits so I'm just going to mouse
over that name and click on alignment in
that pop up menu and that takes me down
the page to the alignment section so
this in fact is a self it this is the
genomic piece that I put in for this
particular strain and we can see here
you can see this is actually that second
methionine the first ATG math I mean and
then if we scroll down a bit here's
another gene another species uses the
same math I mean and scroll down to
another one yet another species of the
same genus it's also using that one so
that's some evidence anyway that it uses
that first ATG is the start of that
particular coding region alright I'm
going to go back to or find or have just
one more example here so I'll go back to
the
submitting page and here I'm going to
input an accession for a bacteriophage
and then this is a much smaller sequence
I'm going to just keep all the defaults
and go ahead and click Submit it found
21 Orff's this time and I just want to
point out so if I had checked the box
for ignore nested Orff's I would have
seen this one this one this one and this
one so it would have gotten four or
fatah these smaller ORS that are
completely enclosed by a larger org and
we're not going to do any analysis here
I'm at about over ten minutes already so
I'm going to wrap this up pretty quickly
I just wanted to point out since you're
in the sequence viewer there's some nice
features here for example you could
download a PDF version of this graphics
view you might want to get rid of the
label first on this orphe by removing
that marker and if you wanted to send a
link of this view to a colleague you go
over here to the pulldown menu next to
the question mark and click on Lincoln
view tells you that this link will be
active for one to two months then you
could send your colleague that tiny URL
there okay that's it for this quick
demonstration remind you if you have any
questions you can write to me or send
those in to info do we have any
questions online Peter all right I will
close the webinar then be sure to check
out our courses and webinars page and
our YouTube channel to find out more
about what we're doing thanks goodbye
you